[Musica]
Come possiamo usare il passato per
prendere decisioni
superato un primo momento di
disorientamento per una domanda così
strana ognuno di voi ha sicuramente
molte risposte Da fornire possiamo usare
le esperienze che abbiamo fatto possiamo
usare le competenze che abbiamo
acquisito possiamo raccogliere
informazioni se non abbiamo abbastanza
esperienza su qualcosa possiamo chiedere
a qualcuno che ne sa più di noi ci sono
tanti modi di usare il passato per
prendere decisioni ma se invece vi
chiedessi Come possiamo usare il futuro
per prendere decisioni
credo che un attimo di maggior
disorientamento potrebbe essere Allora
vorrei raccontarvi un'esperienza di come
si possa usare il futuro per prendere
decisioni e lo farò presentandovi una
specifica esperienza quella i laboratori
di futuro in classe cioè fatti con i
ragazzi parto da un semplice aneddoto
qualche anno fa una collega Emiliana mi
ha invitato a fare un intervento nella
sua scuola perché era molto preoccupata
per l'esito di un esercizio che aveva
fatto con i suoi ragazzi aveva chiesto i
ragazzi di scrivere dei temi su come
vedevano il futuro e si è letteralmente
spaventata la grande totalità per non
dire tutti la grande maggioranza per non
dire la totalità dei ragazzi ha
descritto dei futuri neri disfunzionali
assolutamente problematici Dopodiché
quella che doveva essere una mossa
diciamo intelligente per far maturare
una consapevolezza nei propri ragazzi
rispetto alle sfide che avevano davanti
sarà trasformato in un ostacolo e io le
ho detto Era inevitabile che succedesse
così perché con il futuro non si può
lavorare in modo ingenuo
lavorare con il futuro e Come fare uno
sport c'è bisogno di un riscaldamento
per acquisire un minimo di competenze
dopodiché si riesce a fare un lavoro
effettivo Allora i lavoratori di futuro
in classe sono precisamente questo sono
una esperienza condotta dall'insegnanti
previo ovviamente
una specifica formazione di cui
eventualmente vi dirò qualcosa e sono
strutturati su tre momenti particolari
il primo momento è un ritorno al passato
stiamo parlando di laboratori di futuro
e primo momento è un ad esempio vai a
parlare coi tuoi genitori e fatti
raccontare come era la vita quando loro
avevano la tua età
i problemi che incontravano le
situazioni che dovevano affrontare e
cosa hanno fatto per provare a superarli
e la caratteristica fondamentale di
questa prima fase e far capire ai
ragazzi che i cambiamenti sono normali
ci sono sempre stati e molto
presumibilmente continueranno a esserci
anche negli anni avanti a noi se i
cambiamenti sono normali se gli altri le
generazioni precedenti in un modo o
nell'altro in maniera più o meno
adeguata sono riusciti ad affrontarli
almeno fino a un certo punto ci
riuscirei anche tu non sei più scemo
delle generazioni precedenti come ce
l'hanno fatta i tuoi genitori ce la
farai anche tu ad affrontare le
situazioni e l'obiettivo fondamentale di
questa prima fase è di far abbassare il
livello di ansia
appena il livello di ansia si abbassa
fase numero 2 salto nel futuro diretto
ad esempio cosa vuoi fare da grande
preparo un poster
Descrivi il tuo obiettivo puoi usare
tutto quello che vuoi puoi usare testo
puoi usare fotografie puoi usare musica
non ha importanza usa qualunque modalità
e espressiva ti viene di usare per
descrivere quella che è la tua idea
di futuro il tipo di lavoro che pensi di
poter andare a fare l'insegnante
ovviamente non valuta l'idea perché
quello è il progetto del ragazzo al
massimo può valutare se il poster è
preparato bene Se fate una cosa fatta un
po' in fretta oppure se è curato nei
dettagli cose di questo tipo cioè da una
valutazione più sulla forma che non
sulla sostanza quella sostanza è quella
individuale del singolo del singolo
ragazzo poi la fase critica il passaggio
più importante dell'intera procedura
Immagina che per qualunque motivo il tuo
obiettivo non si possa realizzare
prepara un piano B senza Viverlo come un
fallimento
perché la realtà è sempre più creativa
di qualunque idea di qualunque modello
non si possa avere nella realtà
succedono sempre tante cose che nessuno
poteva in senso proprio anticipare o
prevedere L'importante è avere la
capacità di adeguarsi quell'elemento di
flessibilità che ti aiuta a guardarti
attorno a capire come è fatto l'ambiente
in cui sei inserito e a trovare le
opportunità
che l'ambiente ti offre se una cosa del
genere la impari a 11 anni perché noi il
laboratorio li facciamo anche con le
medie inferiori facciamo anche quelle
elementari ma in quel caso ci sono altri
strumenti da usare è una lezione che ti
porti dietro tutta la vita poi terzo
passaggio gli ho detto tre fasi primo
passaggio un ritorno al passato secondo
passaggio salto nel futuro terzo
passaggio ritorno al presente abbiamo
visto qualcosa dal passato Abbiamo visto
qualcosa dal futuro Adesso cosa facciamo
cioè quali decisioni prendiamo
e micidiale per l'orientamento
per le scelte che i ragazzi devono fare
delle medie inferiori e le medie
superiori e poi delle medie superiori in
università oppure al lavoro a seconda di
quello che decidono di fare notate un
aspetto c'è un elemento critico
assolutamente fondamentale
all'interno di questa struttura mai e
poi mai fare un ragionamento del tipo
passato presente futuro
ma sempre passato futuro presente ovvero
rompere la linearità temporale perché
passato presente futuro suggerisse
continuità ci dice domani sarà come ieri
no domani non sarà come ieri se qualcosa
l'abbiamo capito del futuro è che domani
sarà un'altra storia ci saranno altre
situazioni
ha anche del tutto inimmaginabili
rispetto a quelle che pensiamo oggi
quindi rottura della linearità temporale
passato futuro e poi presente proprio
per aprire nuove possibilità secondo
elemento l'importanza critica del terzo
passaggio dell'arrivo sul presente da
futurista cioè da professionista di
futuro
gli esercizi di futuro devono e sono
fatti per portare a prendere decisioni
un esercizio di futuro che non porti a
decisioni e
un esercizio intellettuale magari una
bella occasione per fare del dei
discorsi assieme ma non è un esercizio
come dire di tipo professionale non
porta a quello che è l'elemento
fondamentale la capacità di prendere
decisioni ho fatto un riferimento
qualcosa di strano Ho parlato di studi
di futuro e cerco di aver Credo di
averlo fatto in maniera concreta di aver
dato un modo per poterli concretizzare
Ovviamente nel contesto delle classi c'è
un media inferiori e superiori in modo
particolare mi ha fatto riferimento
studi di futuro professionista di futuro
queste cose Un po' strane che non si
capisce forse bene che cosa vogliono
dire Allora forse è utile fare un passo
indietro o forse un passo di lato e
chiedersi ma chi altri Sta parlando di
queste cose io non ne ho mai sentito
parlare
Non ho idea che ci sia una possibilità
di diventare professionisti cioè di
acquisire delle competenze
specifiche su queste cose allora chi
altri ne parla in giro per anche per
avere un orientamento
segretario generale delle Nazioni Unite
hour Common l'agenda La nostra azienda
comune sul report dell'anno scorso
in cui dice è necessario riformare le
nazioni unite perché possono essere
ancora più significative nel loro
impatto e parla della cinquina dati del
quintetto il quintetto di nuove
competenze che le nazioni unite devono
Acquisire per essere in grado di
svolgere meglio il ruolo che pensano di
riuscire a svolgere e una di queste
competenze la chiamata strategic forsyte
che quello che poi si intende per studi
di futuro
in azioni unite dicono dobbiamo
acquisire competenze di futuro per
muoverci meglio e riuscire a svolgere in
maniera più efficiente il nostro ruolo e
questo è solo una delle proposte che ha
fatto la seconda proposta che ha fatto e
mi pare che nessuno ne abbia parlato nel
nostro paese è un suggerimento dato a
tutti i paesi di condurre esercizi
nazionali e subnazionali potremmo
tradurli non regionali di futuro
e terzo impegno che si è preso di
convocare ogni due anni un Summit for
the for the future quindi un incontro
internazionale in cui uno dei problemi
fondamentali è quello del futuro
generazione cioè di quello che stiamo
facendo e che di che tipo di mondo
lasceremo a chi verrà dopo di noi
l'azione unite forse non la minima fra
le organizzazioni qui possiamo parlare
Ursula fonderlaia sapete di chi sto
parlando quando è diventata presidente
della commissione europea lei ha preso
due decisioni Cioè ne prese tante ma due
in particolare e ha come dire incaricato
due vicepresidenti della commissione di
seguire
questi due tematiche di cui adesso vi
dico e una è una tematica di cui tutti
hanno parlato l'altra è una tematica di
cui di fatto Nessuno ha parlato la prima
è quella del Green Deal e sapete di cosa
sto parlando serve una politica di
sostenibilità eccetera eccetera Non ho
bisogno di spiegarla perché tutti sanno
di cosa si sta parlando la seconda
è quella di incaricare un vice
presidente della commissione europea di
occuparsi di futuro di strategic forsyte
questa è la terminologia che usano cioè
noi abbiamo un membro della commissione
europea un vice presidente
marossefcovich che si occupa per
incarico istituzionale
di disegnare di vedere di provare a
immaginare i futuri possibili
della commissione europea dell'Europa in
questo caso un incarico istituzionale ai
livelli più elevati
e una delle iniziative cheros ha preso
un'altra delle cose di cui nessuno in
Italia stranamente ha parlato è stata
quella di costituire la rete dei
ministri per il futuro
anche l'Italia ha il suo rappresentante
all'interno di questa rete la rete dei
ministri per il futuro è una rete di
ministri in cui tutti i governi europei
hanno un loro rappresentante Conoscete
un singolo articolo di giornale che ne
abbia parlato E sia chiaro io non credo
che ci sia censura da questo punto di
vista credo che ci sia un sta succedendo
qualcosa attorno a noi che non siamo
stati capaci di vedere c'è una specie di
cecità del paese nel capire alcuni dei
grandi cambiamenti come quelli che vi ho
menzionato che ci stanno circondando
forse il caso di provare a fare qualcosa
Grazie
[Applauso]